we are in problem number 10 problem 10
if 22 X minus 2 x 2 minus x is equal to
0 what are all possible values of x if i
multiply two numbers right i'm
multiplying if i multiply two
expressions than equal to 0 that means
one or both of these expressions are
going to be equal to 0 and if you you
know if you've solved for roots of a
quadratic using factoring you'll be
familiar with this notion so either 2x
minus 20 and or actually either of these
could be equal to 0 or both of them
could be equal 0 so if 2x minus let's
just solve this so add 2 to both sides
2x is equal to 2x is equal to 1 and here
if we just add X to both sides we get 2
is equal to x or x is equal to 2 so X
could be 1 or X could be too so choice D
1 and 2 only and you could try them out
right if X is 1 this becomes 0 x 1 which
is of course 0 if X is 2 this becomes 2
right 2 times 2 minus 2 is 2 times 0
which is 0 and 0 doesn't work and I'm
going to be in your temptation but if
you put 0 in here you get minus 2
because this is this term will go away
you get minus 2 times 2 which is minus 4
so that doesn't work you just have to
set each of these expressions 20 next
question problem 11 11 if X to the third
is equal to y to the ninth what is X in
terms of Y so we can do here is we just
want to get rid of this cubed power so
how do we get rid of the cubed power
well we could take the cube root of both
sides that doesn't make sense to you
I'll show you how x to the third let me
give it give this some breathing room is
equal to y to the ninth I'm just writing
the same thing a little bit bigger
what we do to one side of equation we
can do to the other side of equation if
I want this exponent to be one I just
have to take it to the one-third power
how do I know that well if I take if I
take something to an exponent and then
take it to another exponent I
essentially just multiply the two
exponents right that's an exponent rule
and you can review that in the exponent
videos if you if you multiply 3 and one
third you get one so that's why I'm
raising to the one-third power and that
of course is the same thing as taking
the cube root excuse me I just had some
chicken I need some drink some water or
something but of course if I do
something to one side of the equation I
have to do it to both sides of this
equation right if I raise if I take the
cube root of one side for the equation
to hold have to take the cube root of
the other side so X to the third to the
one-third well that's just X to the
first or just X right because three
times one-third is X is 1 so X to the
first is just X and that equals what y
to the nine times one-third well what's
nine times nine times one-third is equal
to 9 divided by 3 which is equal to
three so X is equal to Y to the third
power that's just this three and that is
choice that is choice C next problem i
will switch colors for variety and
there's something that I have to draw
okay oh they they drew let's see if I
can pull this one off
let's see if I can pull this drawing
this figure off so it looks like a line
like that got a line like that got a
line like that and then I have has
second with some very vintage in line
like that a line like that close enough
and they're asking us they're asking us
in the XY coordinate system above which
of the following line segments has a
slope of negative 1 so what is the slope
of negative 1 a slope of negative 1
means that as we move to the as we move
to the right one as we move to the right
one we move down one that's a slope of
negative one and if you're you know
familiar with slopes a lot just
intuitively you know that it looks
something like this slope of negative
one looks something like that if we look
at the lines that they they drew all the
choices the ones that are moving up are
definitely not our answer right this one
is moving up so this one can't be the
answer this one is moving up so this
can't be the answer this one's moving up
so this one can't be the answer so all
of these lines the yellow ones that I
haven't scratched out all of these have
negative slopes and we just have to
figure out well which one could be
negative one if we look at if we look at
you know this the slope here between 0
point 0 and point a they mark off that
this is you know 1 2 3 and this is one
so for choice for this line we went over
one right we moved over one but we went
down three so this line has a slope of
negative 3 negative 3 and similarly they
draw this goes out 1 2 3 this line we
have to go we have to go three for it to
go we have to move in the X Direction
positive 3 for it to move down 1 so this
has a slope of 1 third and you can kind
of tell that it goes down very gradually
all right the rise actually negative
one-third sorry the rise is negative 1
and
run is three run is just how far you
move in the X direction right this is
the rise is negative 1 which is right
there negative 1 and the run is 3 so
just so we know that this isn't the
answer so just by deducting by deductive
reasoning we know that this is probably
going to be our answer and it also looks
like it has a slope negative 1 and if
you were to actually look at it points D
and C this is points D and C this is
about this is like this it looks like
the point if I just look at it by
inspection 1 comma 3 and this looks like
the point 3 comma 1 right here 3 comma 1
so what is the change in Y over the
change in X well the change in Y is 3
minus 1 so that equals 2 and the change
in X is 1 minus three which is minus 2
which is minus 1 remember when you
calculate slope you always have to use
the first if I use three the first time
in the numerator after use one the first
time in the denominator so 3 minus 1
over 1 minus 3 is the slope and it's
minus 1 but if you're really good you
should just be able to look at it and
say well that's the closest thing to
negative 1 because it's not too steep
and not too shallow next problem oh and
so that is choice D c e choice e
problem 13 problem 13 Kyle's lock
combination consists of three two digit
numbers the combination satisfies the
could the three conditions below one
number one number is odd what number is
odd one is one number is a multiple of
five and then one month is the day of
the month of kyle's birthday so one
number day of month so what do we know
about that number well it has to be it's
a two digit number so it has to be
between 0 1 and 31 right in order for
your birthday it can't be okay if each
number satisfies exactly one of the
conditions which of the following could
be the combination to the lock so each
so one number can't satisfy two of these
conditions and you have you know another
number that satisfies not each of them
has to do one of them so let's look at
the choices choice a choice a is 14 2013
let's see if let's see which one could
satisfy the odd well this number is odd
so let me see if this condition is
satisfied by this number it's odd one
number is a multiple of 5 so let's say
so this condition well that's satisfied
by this number and one number is a day
of the month well this looks pretty
straight forward one number is a
straight day of the month what number is
the day of the month well 14 could be a
day of a month and in general in any s80
problem and i'm seeing this pattern more
and more as i go through all of these
practice tests is when they they have a
problem where they want you to go
through every choice you're the answers
tend to be one of the first few choices
because they don't want to make you to
waste a lot of time so you should feel
pretty comfortable if you do this and
you got choice a and if you know if you
want to see an example of what won't
work I'm guessing be won't work choice B
says
14 14 14 25 13 huh actually that does
look like it could satisfy if each
number satisfies exactly one of the
conditions which of the following could
be the combination to the lock Oh
exactly so why can't this one be because
this this condition that one number is
odd it can only be satisfied by one of
the choices oh I'm running over I'll see
in the next video